cela me laisse froid ou jettent un froid
la pêche qui vient vous bon c'est pas
moi je sens que la menace que c'est une
vrai choc qu'a marqué ce cas c'est dans
la semaine pour un grand retour ainsi
thierry ardisson bertrand piccard mais
non à des rivaux si tu devais j'ai un
doute chanteur je peux limiter
le fait
c'est un patronat
j'aurais dû bosser et mathieu renault
renault qui a dit cette semaine qu'il
avait définitivement arrêté de boire a
lancé la 15e voyant dix ans mais l'idée
quand même et qu'il avait beaucoup
freiné la cigarette il est vrai que
c'est de quatre paquets à 1 1 par contre
il a du mal à trouver l'amour parce
qu'il ne tombe que sur des femmes
mariées et qui se ne fume pas côté macro
pardon qu'il a voté m'a conquis la
botola crans passant 4 à quelques
cafouillages marina et alors il a marqué
aussi bas donc il revient c'est vrai
qu'il n y voit beaucoup plus clair et
tout ça on sent qu'il a il faut un vrai
fort et tant mieux mais il revient parce
que l'émission sur france 2 voilà qui va
s'appeler c'est la soirée anniversaire
de france 2 pourquoi il n'ya pas et il
répond pourquoi ya pas de rappeurs et
joue un petit peu à la mode notamment
sur orelsan et stromae il a dit bah
c'est honnête c'est bien écrit mais
c'est bien écrit mais musicalement je
n'accroche pas cela me laisse froid lui
qui choisissait les diots d'accord il
aurait voulu en faire avec angèle mais
n'étaient pas disponibles il ne veut pas
de rappeur mais ce qui est étrange c'est
que gérard lanvin qui avait fait une
interview sur sud radio avait donné de
ses nouvelles en mars et avait dit mais
pas dans un état disponibles donc ça
peut être qu'il arrêtait a pas longtemps
je pense que l'alcool quand t'arrêtes
en mai dernier album avait fait
uniquement enfin sa voie avait été
travaillé en studio avec un procédé
assez révolutionnaire qui ressemble mais
vocalement audit fake voilà où en gros
c'est pas sa vraie voix donc là tout le
vrai album devrait voir la lumière sur
rtl parce qu'on a fait une journée
spéciale avec lui eh ben on a la vidéo
il va bien est-ce qu'il a chanté on
dirait que regarde comment ça va et plus
en plus de mal à chanter sur ça que j'ai
envisagé de ne pas faire le de tourner
avec cet album ces jeunes et trop galéré
sur les retours des îles ma voie était
ouverte et rocailleuse elle était
toujours depuis un an et demi je dois
faire une goutte d'alcool comme je fume
toujours un bon pied je suis passée de
quelque part et cigarettes par jour un
pas qui je vais pas me faire vacciner
je compte aux accents les crevaisons
interdit le accès au bistrot et j'ai
décidé de faire un ciné wen a étrillé le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà sur lui
on a vu beaucoup de proches et c'est
vrai qu'il était à la fois 13 alcoolique
à l'époque et du parano du coup il se
mettait sur une table souvent au sud de
la france où des têtes raides avignon
qui se mettait sur une table était
complètement comme ça et bougeait pas et
il y avait des gens autour de lui pour
personne de la proche était de la crise
de paranoïa c'était bas c'était très
triste ces dames se mange en tant que la
voie est beaucoup plus clair ce que
croyez moi le précédent album à
consommer avec modération ça c'est clair
pour tout ça c'est sûr
on